how's it going everybody it's Warren and
just a quick heads-up today is the final
day to get 30% off G fuel at G fuel comm
if you use code cosmic so spider-man we
have the MCU and we have the Sony verse
or the Sony spider-verse whatever you
want to call it obviously there was a
ton of drama between the two of them I
don't need to recap that much everybody
knows what happened everybody followed
it spider-man is back in the MCU for a
couple of more films but what happens
now what happens to spider-man story arc
and what happens to some of spider-man's
villains that Sony still owns the rights
to like venom and Morbius well today I
have some good news for you because it's
been reported that the two universes are
finally going to collide and they're
going to be connected by one character
and it's not the character that you
would expect it to be it's not Peter
Parker slash spider-man nope it is the
one and only J jonah Jameson as it seems
JK Simmons is character JJJ is going to
be the character that connects the Sony
verse to the MCU so let's break down the
report and what it means reminder I'm
still doing my xbox one and ps4 giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed to my channel like the video
and comment with your favorite superhero
or villain so recently there has been a
lot of talk about JK Simmons his
character Jay jonah Jameson appearing in
the upcoming Jared Leto movie Morbius
now Morbius is a spider-man character
that Sony owns the rights to he
originally debuted in the amazing
spider-man number 101 and of course the
movie is already in development right
now over at Sony coming out in July of
2020 with Jared Leto cast to play
Morbius and although Morbius is a
spider-man character with the Sony
spider-verse being separate from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe nobody
expected anything from Tom Hollands
spider-man to be included in this movie
however that is until now it has been
reported that JK Simmons will be
reprising his role as Jay jonah Jameson
in the upcoming Morpheus film
effectively connecting the Morbius film
that will exist in the Sony Universe to
spider-man
far from home that exists in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and this report comes
from Thomas Pulido of geeks worldwide
now this is actually a really big deal
it's the start to something
pretty big it's the first step to having
Sony spider-verse connect to and
interact with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with Tom Hollands spider-man
now we know that Sony has wanted this
for some time now because we know that
Sony wanted Tom Hollands spider-man to
cameo in venom Marvel was the side with
resistance to that however we do know
that Sony and Disney / Marvel just
worked out a deal we don't really know
the specifics of this deal however we do
know that it does seem like the worlds
are colliding with Marvel sharing the
character J jonah Jameson who was in the
MCU and spider-man far from home with
Sony in their spider-verse film Morbius
now this is just the start what this is
most likely leading up to and this is
just my speculation at this point is
venom we recently had a plot leak for
venom two that says Tom Hollands
spider-man will cameo in it at the very
end setting up spider-man to be in venom
3 and with Jay jonah Jameson being in
the MCU and in the spider verse this
sets up spider-man to be in both the MCU
and the spider verse as well and if we
have a film with spider-man who exists
in the MCU and exists in the spider
verse interact with a venom that means
that venom will exist in both universes
as well so this is a big deal this is a
character that connects the two
universes together that could ultimately
lead to a bigger connection and a bigger
crossover which is something that a lot
of people have wanted for a very long
time now so what do you think about this
news what do you think about Jay jonah
Jameson connecting the two universes
together I think it's awesome I think it
would be really funny just to see him on
TV and that little tidbit right there is
what really connects the universes but
let me know what you think leave a
comment down below and also don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU and the spider-verse
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof